and of course ted who's been a big fan
of zion who isn't
you have some great suggestions as far
as when to avoid the area because of all
the flooding we just talked about this
too
a friend of mine also went to flagstaff
to go
camping yeah in july and august and he
got caught in those storms
not a good time to be out there east of
us with those this time of the season
because monsoon season officially
starts for las vegas uh next week but
we've seen an early
start to the monsoon season already
seeing some storms last week and also
today
we're looking up to the north here now
you can see the storms billowing up this
is in lincoln county where
we're getting more of the stronger
storms out there while here
really nothing with all the clouds we
had earlier today we picked up an
additional 100
of an inch from those showers we saw
this morning a lot of you we talked
about that from nate and sherry this
morning
so that gives us 200 of an inch for the
month so far we'll take it right
this is where we should be though for
the month so we will take any raindrops
we can get 93 in sky canyon right now
same for centennial hills
we're at 89 up there in aliante 92 north
las vegas 91 sunrise manor
double eight for you and whitney ranch
southern highlands 92 the point is
we are not going to reach 100 degrees
officially for sure in the valley today
after that nice cool down we had this
morning
all the cloud cover we had this morning
we are of course reaching triple digits
though in death valley
97 in trump 98 loflin right now and 93
currently in mesquite let's get to the
radar most of the storms have been
really favoring mohave county again and
now we're seeing a really fire up that's
the one i pinpointed out there at tower
camp
up in lincoln county and central nye but
i am watching this one right now coming
in from the west
no lightning detected with this one but
it is holding together so we'll see if
it makes its way over the spring range
over sr 160 and gives us some showers
here we hope so
so we are tracking that future cast
shows tonight
as we lose that daytime heating the
chances for thunderstorms starts to
diminish
for later on tonight i'm not entirely
taking it out of the forecast
it's not going to be as widespread or as
abundant as like we had
last night but slight chances are still
out there
rain chances go up again believe this or
not thunderstorm chances
go up again a little for the weekend we
still have some moisture still
around the region and still some heating
we expect for the weekend that could
fire up those storms
82 overnight still some chances of
isolated storms before 10 pm
105 for tomorrow mostly sunny and hotter
there's that slight chance tomorrow
mainly favoring the mountains
look at your highs tomorrow around 102
for summerlin 104
for north las vegas 103 for mountains
edge
aliante 104 107 green valley 103
for henderson so today we were only in
the 90s
tomorrow we're right back to triple
digits and we're going to be right near
average for tomorrow kyle canyon nice
and cool up there at 84 tomorrow
highs across the region 102 for prompt
103 for boulder city
112 for you and laughlin gonna be hotter
in death valley of course
at 117 degrees tomorrow afternoon now
here is your eight day forecast here on
channel eight we call it the eight on
the eight
there's that slight chance tomorrow each
day of course gets a little hotter
this weekend on the fourth of july yes
we have slight chances there
not a big chance slight chances and then
next week we slowly start to dry out
with more sunshine for next week
possibly getting back to 110 again
as early as wednesday certainly on
thursday
next week that is your most accurate
forecast
let's go to denise valdez live in our
eight news now newsroom with what's
coming up
at five either ted did the phrase that
you use a lot this time of years we're
trading the heat for the humidity and it
sounds like this is the pattern network
we said that last night yeah i know